au mir aujourd'hui votre combat c'est
d'essayer de sauver le maximum de
personnes qui sont dans ces cons adresse
leur tour tous le braille à tous les
chercheurs il dit évidemment c'est pour
ces gens pour ce peuple donc pour qu'il
crée son envie moi pour qu'ils peuvent
vivre ans en comment un être humain
c'est pas trop demander
aujourd'hui pour lui il pourra plus
jamais avoir une vie normale il est il
est traumatisé il est cassé que sa
famille aussi puisqu'il vit avec sa
famille où les idiots au lond il arrive
à un ici voilà de 2,2 de penser à autre
chose parfois où c'est toujours dans cet
état
outre leur combat mais de gecimed voilà
il dit depuis trois ans il est sorti il
a juste attendu que son père qui décide
et un pour le reste pour sa mère pour
ses proches pour ses frais pour ses
soeurs qu'il sait même pas qu'ils sont
en vie ou non
ouroux ils sont donc donc voilà si si il
dit il pense tout le temps à ça parce
que ce que en gros on peut dire le quand
il était au camp quand il est sorti
salon les s'il était libéré
montbazens temps allait partir de gaza
ce temps apprécié l'idée tient quand
même deux responsables que toute sa
famille qui était ami dans le camp à
cause de lui donc voilà c'est ça qui
tient et il peut pas
lâcher maintenant il veut aller jusqu'au
bout aujourd'hui il travaille au long
non il est arrivé par longtemps leur
tacot l'instant j'apprends encore
d'accord ils arrivent à s'en sortir à
vivre avec sa famille au début il était
tout seul sa femme il est resté au en
turquie maintenant il ya quelques mois
vraiment récent pennant réunis et
maintenant ils étaient cent lieues
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il a envie de
dire à à emmanuel macron ce soir si l'on
regarde le président français ce qui est
ce qu'on a là là là le poids pour
essayer de faire bouger les choses je
sais que les américains essaient de
faire bouger les choses aussi ou est-ce
qu'il ya rien à faire que les chine le
gouvernement chinois ne bougera pas
présentera à prendre je ne regarde pas
ce qu'il souhaite que ma combien vaut
aux autres dirigeants
il veut dire que voilà il faut arrêter
cette gêne aussi mais surtout qu'il faut
agir plus vite possible pour sauver les
vies des gens pour qu'ils peuvent vivre
humainement
normalement il dit que c'est tout le
dirigeant ensemble en commun comment on
peut dire il te faire faucher les choses
voilà bouger les choses
qu'ils soient tous en toile